let's bring in Kurt Warner Kurt Warner
working with NFL Network you can follow
the NFL Network analyst Kurt Warner on
his Twitter handle at curt 13 warner and
he's alive from Giants training camp
today and you can see his reports on NFL
Network Kurt thanks for joining us is
there a quarterback controversy with the
Giants no there is not a controversy yes
I'm going to say yes now come on this is
this is Eli Manning's job I mean I think
the bottom line with this whole
situation is how the team plays is you
know you always have this situation you
have a young guy team doesn't start
really well that's to me when the
questions are going to start to arise
when is the right time to insert Daniel
Jones for the future but no I don't
believe there's any controversy I
believe this is Eli's job he will start
the season and he'll play well into the
season until until maybe there's some
questions about where the team stands
okay but making this transition and
eventually there will be a transition to
Daniel Jones because you wasted way
didn't waste who spent a top 10 draft
pick on him so at some point you have to
see what he can do on the football field
try to troubleshoot this Kurt where do
you think we see maybe a transitional
moment where the Giants find out what
they have at quarterback I mean I think
the perfect scenario for the Giants is
to play Eli Manning this year or however
long that is until it's time for him to
pyranha then you move to Daniel Jones I
don't think anybody wants to insert the
young kid for Eli Manning in the middle
of a season I don't think that's the way
they want to uh sure Eli Manning out but
like I said a lot of it is going to
depend on the pressure that comes when
you're struggling as a football team or
if Eli is struggling to some degree and
then you have to fight that battle it's
so different because you're talking
about a Giants icon you know you're not
talking about a situation like I was in
here so many years ago where I was a guy
that was just keeping the spot warm
until they felt it was time this is a
completely different situation that's a
lot more sensitive than
a first sign of anything but to put
Daniel Jones in that's not how it's
gonna work so I think the Giants would
love to have Eli play 16 games and then
be able to reassess it going into next
year so you don't have to make that you
know sticky transition you know from the
icon guide to the young guy do you agree
with the Giants that taking you know
Daniel Jones that that was something
that they had to do they couldn't pass
on this guy I mean I don't believe it
based on what I saw in college you know
I don't think he was a guy that you must
have type guy didn't you know possess
certain things that you say wow this is
a once-in-a-lifetime type guy to get him
at number six but you know I mean a lot
of that isn't determined yet a lot of
guys have to grow and become different
guys when they get to the NFL than they
were in college but just based on what I
saw I wasn't necessarily wowed with his
college tape to the point where I go oh
this guy's top 10 or top six pick in the
NFL Draft yeah but it feels like the
Giants are moving on but they're still
stuck in neutral here by having Eli out
there Kurt I don't understand what
they're doing and as a fan of a team all
I would want to know is tell me what our
game plan is that we have won and I
don't know if the Giants have won if you
keep Eli in there for one year or two
more years you've gotten rid of Odell
Beckham jr. got rid of some
personalities there and I have say Quan
Barkley that I don't want to waste his
good years in these seasons where we're
gonna struggle to win six or seven games
yeah I mean I understand exactly where
you're coming from but the problem just
becomes what how do you deal with Elon
does he not has he not earned the right
to finish and kind of write his own
ending if he can still play at a high
level if he's equal to or better than
Daniel generals does he not deserve the
right to be able to play that thing out
or you know or you just saying hey we've
drafted this guy doesn't matter whether
he's the best guy or not we're gonna
play him I just think that's a sticky
situation when you don't get about a
giant Hall of Famer like like Eli guy
who spent so much on two championships
and he's done well in the postseason
he's not a great regular-season
quarterback and I don't know if he's
gonna have numbers where you're gonna
you know keep the barbarians from the
gate calling for him to be benched he
right I think the Giants it's a classy
organization but you can't put one
player above everybody else in the
future of this team and either don't
spend that draft pick Kurt or just say
that Eli is our quarterback I one way or
another but it I just don't think you
can do both I completely understand
where you're coming from but like I said
I think this is just different so many
situations aren't like that because you
don't have the income a guy that's been
there so long and done so well and me
that has meant so much to an
organization because they don't have
that if you're going to get that guy
that high you know you've got a more of
a transition guy where it becomes easier
to make that decision you're almost
looking for the opportunity to make that
decision and put the young guy in I just
don't know how you deal with that with a
guy like Eli Manning I don't think you
can sit here and go okay let's wait for
him to slip up and then Joe Daniel
Jonesy and I I just don't think it works
that way with where the Giants are right
now one other item I wanted to ask it
has nothing to do with the Giants camp
but it was a couple years ago where
there was a report there was going to be
a movie made on your life and I don't
know where does that move east and that
script stands there's gonna be a movie
based on Kurt Warren
yeah knocking home my breasts we're
still actually working on it that's with
some some writers again actually last
weekend so piecing it together and
trying to get the script right and so it
can happen but you know with this
Hollywood stuff sometimes it takes
longer than we all wanted to but it
still in the works and it still moving
forward to some degree but again I'm not
telling my chickens until they're
hatched
wait who's gonna play you Kurt whose
depend on when we actually get this
movie done take it right now it's not
going to get done for another seven or
eight years so once we get that script I
think we can kind of start to streamline
who we might want to play the different
parts and I don't know if Bradley Cooper
can throw a football or
Ryan Reynolds but you know I'm guessing
your wife would probably want someone
like that to play okay yeah I'll take
either one of those guys
sounds good to me she would love that as
well Oh the other item I saw and I was
gonna ask you about this you don't have
Russell Wilson as one of the top five
quarterbacks in the NFL is that is that
correct yeah I did not on my list this
year I actually had him tied at number
five big band but for TV I gave Ben a
slight edge over over Russell but you
know you can ask when we talk about
quarterbacks sometimes I always say
there's no quarterback in the league
that I would rather have two minutes to
go in a game than Russell Wilson now
that doesn't mean I want him the rest of
the game because I think there are times
when he's not a guy you can load up and
make him pass all the time he has to
benefit from a running game a good
defense but two minutes to go I'd take
him over Brady I'd take him over Aaron
Rodgers I think he's phenomenal with the
you know game on the line two minutes to
go
how much does that factor in if I just
said game is on the line where is
Russell Wilson in that mix of those guys
ahead of him that factors way and I mean
you know I would that's one of the crack
categories I always look at it how are
they in the biggest moments and I agree
with you 100% that Russell Wilson is one
of the best two three four quarterbacks
in the league in the last he's a winner
you keep the game close which he usually
does because it doesn't make a lot of
mistakes and you're right put the ball
in his hands and he's going to make that
special play to give you an opportunity
to win and so that's way up on the board
I think kind of like you said it's the
every down every situation passing type
situations that I think knocked him down
a little bit for me and I've always
biased to because I played the game a
certain way so I see the game a certain
way and so I think sometimes these
running quarterbacks or athletic
quarterbacks that do some of those extra
stuff I'm not sure I weigh that as
heavily as I should because I see the
game a little bit differently but I
agree with you as far as a winner
there's not too many guys in the league
that I would choose over Russell Wilson
if I said you had to take Carson Wentz
this season or Cam Newton this season
Wow it's a great question I'm probably
going to take carson wentz
i think my biggest concern is just
camping and health he's he's taking so
many hits and you're coming off a
shoulder surgery that always worries me
as a quarterback that you know in carson
what he was a couple years ago i think
now that a year under his belt i think
he can give back more to that form so
yeah that was a close one but I would
probably just lead towards Carson just
because of the health factor good to
talk to you Kurt and have fun play nice
their giant scam all right man good to
talk to you too that's Kurt Warner you
can see his report on NFL Network
starting at 3:00 Eastern as they're
taking a spin around all the training
camps there for more Dan Patrick show
tune in the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]